thor and beta ray bill come to fortnight
new crossover pois on the way
and weapon charms finally arrive let's
talk about fortnite
season four
[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's my favorite time of the fortnight
cycle
the week before the new season drops and
we all look for clues and leaks to
figure out
what to expect next season this time
though
there is a hulking great lawsuit hanging
over the game and many of the audience
are unable to update their app so if i'm
honest
i'm expecting the current season to be
extended probably right after i upload
this video
hmm yeah that's my look anyway i've been
looking over all the info from those
lovely leakers and match those up with
emails and live events from past
fortnight seasons
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes
slap code adamara in the store to
support these shenanigans
and let's uncover what fortnite chapter
2 season 4
will look like
august 27th that's the date we've been
given and holy heck balls batman
this actually could be the first season
of chapter two to stick to that time
scale
the devs have been testing out the new
season privately but some of the coding
is already in the game and leakers
have revealed many things let's start
with what we are most confident about
four over the season we've had many
indications that the god of thunder is
coming to br
remember how captain america arrived he
was using asgardian tech
the bifrost a link between multiple
worlds
thanks to a gatekeeper the most famous
one being heimdall
by using a sword-shaped key they all see
can send someone
anywhere in any realm and by the looks
of it
cap used it and the only way cap could
have got access to this
is through four shortly after we were
given the dad bod johnsy
which is almost identical to thor in his
gamer days
then another leaker for tori found these
riff runes in the game
files so adding all this information
together we are confident of another
marvel themed season dropping later this
month but wait
there's more i'm sure you've seen by now
that many console gamers had an
additional element in their fortilla
screen
i usually say tortilla for the sake of
this video i will use its real name
on the fortilla it's possible to see a
comic book
but this isn't just any comic book it's
a real world item which was released
this year 2020. it's a new thor story
which gives us so many clues about his
future
i bought it gave it to reed and here's
the story that it tells
skip ahead if you don't want any
spoilers just in case this links
directly to fortnite
the story starts with thor throwing his
hammer from asgard
through 10 realms to slay a beast on
earth
helping out the avengers by the time he
calls it back the hammer now has a
message from tony stark written on it
which reads nice shots enjoy your
retirement
so right away we know this isn't the
movie universe
this thor is now the all father and his
hammer grows heavier each day
suddenly out of nowhere galactus appears
and thor
jumps into action galactus is like a
world
devouring entity and a definite bad guy
here
but here's where things get strange he's
not here to fight thor
he declares something worse is coming
the black winter
and then he passes out we find out that
the black winter is here to end
all life thor discovers that galactus is
the only entity to
ever survive the black winter and even
though he's the bad guy
he's the only way to save the worlds so
thor must take galactus to five
different planets with elemental energy
he will then consume them and become
strong enough to face the black winter
and prevent it from wiping everything
out but giving that much power to a bad
guy
who eats worlds may not be the greatest
of ideas
just saying to compound all this
galactus hits thought with something
called cosmic
energy making thor the herald of thunder
and that's the picture you can see in
fortnite right now and that's the end of
the first issue
in the next one though thor leads
galactus to the first planet for him to
eat for lunch
but notices that this is full of living
beings and stops galactus from consuming
it
galactus isn't happy and threatens to
take away thor's cosmic energy
so thor throws his hammer through
galactus hand
and then um his kneecap too wow
yeah pretty pretty violent thor then
uses the bifrost to take the world's
inhabitants
back to asgard allowing galactus to
consume the planet safely
let's pause right there because this
could lead to two live events
in fortnite the first could see a huge
version of galactus appear
kinda like travis scott did and attempt
to consume our planet
only for thor to step in and save us
from annihilation imagine watching that
kind of like the star wars event but
even more epic
that would give us a great set piece
without breaking the story of ego
or agent johnsy alternatively thor could
arrive and whisk us all to asgard for a
season
protecting us against galactus and
giving us something different to do
there are so many ways this comic book
could impact the spectacle of fortnite
and to go even further down this rabbit
hole we can look at the evidence in
chapter one
we all notice the similarities to the og
island for example
the first season we didn't get a live
event in the third season we saw meteors
crash down
and that happened this season the two
islands seem to be sharing a common
narrative
and if we remember what happened in
chapter one season four rightly
superheroes now epic has a tight
relationship with marvel and dc
reliving that season again with
recognizable superheroes instead of
rip-off versions
could be mind-blowing it's either that
or space again
but space has been the constant
narrative throughout the last three
years
the meteor the spaceship the rift the
giant mech
everything is linked to space travel and
the one superhero who can jump between
worlds instantly
is thor and his bifrost well actually
the best one for this would be silver
surfer but he's not gonna suddenly to
hang on
he's in that comic series too wow and to
compound this even more
remember season five of chapter one that
was the season which saw real world
items appear in game
and a few which came the other way too
like loot llamas in london
the comic book is in game right now for
some people and if this is a
continuation of this
maybe it was agent jones's and somehow
it made it
into the fortnite world agent johnsy
has many questions to answer for us
before i completely move away from comic
books for a while
should it line up that series also has
beta ray bill
and lady sith as key members and
potential skins
let's go to the world of movies instead
remember the weird artifact we all
spotted under the steamy stacks building
it looks like an airplane black box with
a strange key standing upon it
what we missed at the time was the audio
cue this
sound
as unnerving as it is it's taken from a
film named
tenet a film directed by chris nolan who
has a good relationship with fortnite
this is an official crossover but a key
one i'd love to try and break down the
reason it's here but the film isn't out
yet
so i'm gonna need your help why is the
tenant key here
and what does it mean could this
location be changing
speaking of changing locations and pois
one of the greatest things that was
added back in season nine of chapter one
was the crossover poi none other than
john wick's house
was recreated and so was the hotel he
works at too
this led to the wix bounty game modes
then in season x we
saw a borderlands tie-in and then we got
the mind-blowing gotham city for
batman's birthday
these were unbelievably successful for
fortnite
and then in chapter 2 season 2 the
crossovers grew massively with deadpool
and his yacht appearing
the detail here was insane and to top
all that off we currently have aquaman
and a form of atlantis is here these
mid-season map changes are now a key
part of fortnite
so we should expect this to continue
thor could bring us asgard
and i'm hoping to find kog playing
fortnite so we're good here mate oh wow
shut the front door
the thor crossover was signaled years
ago how do we miss this
man that's impressive before we
speculate too much let's go back a
little and
see what we should expect from the next
season 100
every fortnight shot tells us of new
skins or items coming
i'm not saying that the apple skin is
coming soon maybe that's
too too soon right but did you pay
attention to the weapons in the joyride
update video
another new shotgun was previewed for a
split second
this is becoming a trend to reveal
weapons in images
and not talk about them until they
release and look at this guy
he has a freaking torch could we be
lighting structures ablaze in season
four
it certainly looks that way right now
those items are used to light areas in
creative mode
this could actually easily become a
limited time mode
maybe call it lights out a darkness
covers the map and we can only see 20
feet in front of us
and the only thing over long distances
we can spot are the flames of other
players
how cool would that be in addition to
new weapons we're getting a fishing
update next season
i know that sounds about as fun as
watching paint dry but hear me out
the fishing mechanic has become a key
strat in pro games
and by varying the loot pool no pun
intended
this should be able to be a bigger part
of casual play too
leakers have found a whole shed load of
fish to find next season
which will likely be another punch card
we'll need to wait to see how each fish
operates
but it should be interesting to say the
least and like fortnite always does
there's an easter egg in game right now
which foreshadows this update
check out this poster hidden in plain
sight
brilliant here's an interesting one
remember years ago when we knew epic
were adding a loadout function to
fortnite but then we had to wait
over a year for it to be implemented
in-game well there's another system you
should be aware of
weapon trinkets most people like to call
these charms a lucky item you take with
you on your missions
games like rainbow six siege and call of
duty use these
extensively as they flap about on your
weapon but they are first person
shooters
and that item doesn't translate well to
third person games like fortnite
to rectify this there are two solutions
bring the first person perspective back
to the game
we had it in save the world it's
nauseating when you try and crank a 90
and i would love to see professional
players try to play in first person view
they would blow chunks when they're
building their little thoughts
anyway i digress the other alternative
is to make them part of a back bling
simple but effective i personally would
like to see hats
or masks added to the game but i'm
guessing i'll be waiting a few more
years
whereas weapon trinkets or character
charms could be a thing
as soon as season four next week
if i can get my batman skin to rock a
marvel charm the world
will be a better place
so what do you think will happen in
chapter 4 and beyond i'd love to know
your thoughts
i have so much more to share but i don't
want to make this video too long like i
have a kevin the cube theory
we'll leave that for the time being on
screen now are the legends roll call
people who've used code adamaru in the
store thank you so much
when penny came over to br over 1 000
people used my code
wow my brain is melting with gratitude
thank you so much
i know many of you are just using my
code for a one-off because it was penny
and i really appreciate that too so
thank you very much
i'll continue to reply to twitter dms
this week so sorry if i haven't replied
already
i will get to you i'm adam from
playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
time